l' agence france-presse
monsieur le président vous aviez indiqué
pendant la campagne que vous consulterez
des experts sur la nécessité de
reprendre ou non les essais nucléaires
avez vous arrêté votre position ici oui
quelle est elle bah je croire en effet
que le moment est venu pour la france
d'arrêter une décision définitive dans
le domaine de ces essais nucléaires
alors naturellement nous préférerions
tous ne pas avoir à reprendre d'essai
nucléaire
malheureusement nous les avons arrêtés
un peu trop tôt en avril 92 c'est à dire
avant que la série qui devait nous
permettre d'achever ne soit terminée
j'ai donc consulté tous les experts
civils et militaires compétents et
responsables pour qu'ils me donnent leur
sentiment sur les conséquences de cet
arrêt la possibilité de maintenir le
moratoire ou au contraire la nécessité
de terminer les essais interrompus
je peux vous dire qu'ils ont été
unanimes unanime pour m'indiquer que si
nous voulions assurer la sûreté la
sécurité et la fiabilité de nos forces
de dissuasion sur lesquelles repose
notre défense et notre indépendance
si nous voulions passer au stade de la
simulation en laboratoire dont on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est à dire la
possibilité
de faire dans des laboratoires des
expériences keane qui sont travers les
ordinateurs et des technologies
naturellement moderne mais sans avoir à
recourir à des essais en vraie grandeur
si nous voulions le faire
nous étions obligés d'achever cette
série d'essais nucléaires
j'ai donc vous savez que ces essais se
passent dans le pacifique sud que ils
ont lieu dans des conditions où centre
entrer dans les polémiques il n'y a
strictement aucune conséquences
écologiques comme ont pu le constater de
nombreux spécialistes étrangers et
s'avance étrangers venus sur les sites
et j'ai d'ailleurs indiqué que dans le
cadre de l'achèvement de nos essais il y
aurait deux possibilités pour toutes les
personnalités scientifiques compétents
de venir constater sur place
le fait qu'il n'y a aucune conséquences
écologiques dans ses essais les essais
nécessaires sont au nombre de huit
ils interviendront à partir du mois de
septembre et seront en tous les cas
terminé fin mai 1996 quand tous les cas
peut-être avant mais en tous les cas
famille 96 j insiste sur ce point parce
que vous le savez c'est à l'automne 96
que va arriver à terme et à signature si
j'ose dire le traité portant
interdiction le traité international
portant interdiction de tout essai
nucléaire et la france a bien
l'intention de signer sans réserve ce
traité en automne 96 portant
interdiction
de tout essai nucléaire mais pour ce
faire il fallait naturellement qu'elles
soient en situation d'assurer je voulais
dit tout à l'heure à la fois la sécurité
et la sûreté et la fiabilité de sa force
de dissuasion et qu' elle est aussi la
possibilité comme l'ont d'autres pays de
passer à la simulation
j'ajoute que mon objectif est de
permettre à la france d'avoir une
sécurité renforcée pour un coot moindre
essai possible n'entrerez pas
aujourd'hui dans le détail de ce point
de vue mais j'ai demandé également au
gouvernement
dans cet esprit aussi d'examiner les
conditions de fermeture du site d'albion
non je ne suis pas certain qu'il
corresponde aujourd'hui à une nécessité
le gouvernement met fraport sur ce point
bien entendu dans l'hypothèse où cette
fermeture serait décidée il va de soi
que la reconversion du site par une
autre activité offrant les mêmes
caractéristiques en termes d'emploi et
en termes d'activité économique serait
cela va de soit assurée donc après mûre
réflexion
après large consultation
j'ai pris la décision parce que je la
considérais nécessaires aux intérêts
supérieurs de notre nation d'autoriser
la fin de cette campagne d'essai et
cette décision est naturellement tu
irrévocable
claude cabanes l'humanité monsieur le
président est ce que vous ne craignez
pas que la reprise des essais nucléaires
par la france ne nuisent beaucoup à son
image dans le monde d'une part et
d'autre part n'encourage les puissances
non nucléaire à se doter de l'armé
nucléaire et donc relance la course aux
armements
sur le deuxième point il y a une
signature et la france y apprit
diplomatique très actif du traité de
non-prolifération
je crois que ces 178 pays qui l'ont
signé si je ne m'abuse
par conséquent il ne peut pas y avoir de
conséquence de cette nature le traité de
non-prolifération s'imposer je répète la
france ému un rôle très actif dans le
fait que beaucoup de pays
réservez l'ont signée comme nous des
réactions dans certains pays ou dans
certaines opinions publiques
je n'en doute pas d'autant qu'ils sont
des sujets complexes et qui souvent
provoque des réactions passionnelles
je respecte les opinions de tous je ne
polémique avec personne j'ai pris le
soin d'informer soigneusement tous les
personnalités en france et à l'étranger
qui devait l'être de ma décision et je
n'ai polémiquer avec personne je dis
seulement que et c'est ma responsabilité
je suis certain que cette décision est
conforme à l'intérêt national à
l'indépendance nationale et que par
conséquent je me devais de l'apprendre
suppression libération avec vous prévenu
les gouvernements de nouvelle zélande et
d'australie
et quand j'ai prévenu aujourd'hui les
gouvernements de nouvelle zélande et
d'australie mais pour ne rien vous
cacher j'avais eu l'occasion de
rencontrer le premier ministre néo
zélandais le 8 mai à paris nous avions
déjà évoqué ce sujet sa surprise ne
devrait pas être grande
vous reprendre le problème des essais
nucléaires est ce que vous ne craignez
pas que certains pays qui ont déjà
l'arme atomique ne procèdent eux
également à certains essais en suivant
l'exemple de la france et est ce que on
peut avoir une idée de la tonalité des
réactions des chefs d'état que vous avez
prévenu
je laisserai aux chefs d'état que j'ai
prévenu le soin de d'exprimer eux mêmes
leurs positions je ne suis pas leur
porte parole
j'ai fait ce qui devait être fait bien
entendu je ne pense pas que ce soit de
nature à encourager certains qui
n'auraient pas fait décès à en faire
chacun sait que la france avait
interrompu ses essais pour des raisons
je peux parfaitement comprendre mais
alors qu'elle terminait son programme et
que donc lcd temps [ __ ] et d'un certain
nombre d'informations que l'on pouvait
juger inutile ou au contraire nécessaire
c'est que ce n'est pas des essais que ce
ne sont pas des essais destinés à
améliorer par exemple les performances
de nos armes
évidemment pas le cas donc je ne vois
pas en quoi cela pourrait inciter ou
encourager ceux qui ont décidé un
moratoire de leur essai c'est à dire
essentiellement les américains et des
russes en faire de nouveaux les chinois
vous le savez continue de faire des
essais oh le joli airtel quelle
personnalité avez-vous prévenu en france
avez-vous prévenus notamment des membres
de l'opposition
des responsables de l'opposition ce que
j'ai pu joindre
oui et notamment le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
et cela va de soi mon prédécesseur
monsieur mitterrand
[Musique]